[Music]
I gotta get back
Oh God hey pasa man he's just sorry just
you in that chair I think I woulda made
a damn fine president you would have
brought a real dignity to the office
you're welcome America
welcome to Zombieland
life is about more than just survival we
were a family dysfunctional sure but
what family isn't very perfect what
would you like little girl I really like
for you to stop calling me little girl
but you know what I would like I don't
give a [ __ ] what you it felt so good to
be on the move again
ohh oh my god I'm so sorry hi I'm
Columbus this is Tallahassee hey pop
Larry this your dad
[Music]
Oh whoopsie I forgot the default wrong
oh so she knows the rules I told her
just a few of her 73 oh and are there
more they're cute I will like it
my sister is gone she picked up the boy
he's from Berkeley Berkeley even that
weed Dave do I look like the type of
person that would have weed I'm sorry
boom yeah have nothing against it be SOT
just wanna beat the [ __ ] out of we're
gonna go get her we write it down start
talking you first
[Music]
[Music]
my right oh my apologies little Elvis is
it me or does he kind of remind you of I
don't like you at all
I think you're double-parked one more
perpendicular parks hope we don't get it
is going on here
what hello everyone my hellos Nene
[Music]